predawn's sky lit up as russian rockets
fall in chassis vr an apartment block
torn apart rescue workers know the
timing of the attack means most people
would have been in bed so they're moving
debris by hand tunneling down trying to
find anyone still trapped in the
building
what have we done to them what have our
people done to hurt them there was
darkness and then it all started
locals could only look on helpless as
the search continued for neighbors
friends
relatives
we ran to the basement there were three
hits the first somewhere in the kitchen
the second i don't even remember there
was lightning we ran towards the second
entrance and then straight into the
basement we sat there all night until
this morning
the local governor says there may be
many more people trapped in the rubble
having lifting gear is on standby
again we have one more confirmation of
war crimes by the russian federation
they are targeting civilians everywhere
towns villages and cities it doesn't
matter if they are on the front line or
somewhere else
the president's chief of staff called it
another terrorist attack by a terrorist
country and he demanded governments act
to declare russia a state sponsor of
terrorism the russians have repeatedly
denied the target civilians
two u.s senators have pushed the idea of
designating russia a state sponsor of
terrorism and they believe they could
get almost unanimous support for it in
the u.s senate that would put russia in
the same category as north korea iran
and syria and the vote could follow in
coming days
alan fisher al-jazeera kiev